[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIELS PROVOS: Good
afternoon, everybody.
I'm glad that you're
still with us.
I know it's late in the day.
The session is not
going to be interesting.
I'll just be talking
about security.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm Niels Provos.
I'm a distinguished
Engineer at Google.
I've been there
for about 13 years.
These days, I manage the
security and engineering--
security and privacy
engineering teams.
Today I want to
talk to you about
our 10-year-plus experience in
securing and building Google's
internal Cloud platform.
That infrastructure is
the foundation that really
powers all of our services.
And it's what you end
up using, whichever way
you end up consuming Google.
Either as a user of
our consumer offerings
or as an enterprise
customer of GCP or G Suite.
And I'm here today to give
you a more detailed overview
of Google's comprehensive
approach to security
and help you better understand
how your own business on top
of GCP benefits and can
leverage all the security
work that we have done
over the last 10 years.
Before I get started, let's talk
a little bit about the threats
that we are facing
in today's world.
Unfortunately, we
continue to live in a time
where companies end up getting
compromised frequently.
If I pick up a newspaper
and see another story
of a large compromise, I'm
no longer really surprised.
The scope of these compromises
can be quite large.
You may be remembering
Yahoo in 2013.
They lost 1 billion accounts.
The sophistication of the
adversaries is also very high.
It includes
state-sponsored actors
with corresponding resources.
Just think back to
the 2016 elections,
where the Russians
compromised the DNC.
Unfortunately, this
is not really a trend
that is unlikely to stop.
I mean, this is not
a trend that's likely
going to stop anytime soon.
So you know, the natural
question that I ask myself,
and that you might also
be asking yourself is,
what should we do about that?
Many companies these days
have started to realize that
security cannot be ignored.
And that building an effective
security engineering team
is something that they have to
do, but is quite challenging.
And it's challenging because
not only is it very expensive.
There's also a fierce
competition for the talent.
So in my perhaps
somewhat biased opinion,
the cloud, where
you can build on top
of professionally managed
and secure infrastructure,
is really the only
viable solution.
As you will see
for Google's cloud,
we are focused on designing
in defense in depth
throughout out the stack.
And that's what I
want to talk to you
about through the
remainder of this talk.
We strongly believe
that trust needs
to be gained through
transparency.
And for that reason,
we recently released
the Google infrastructure
security design overview.
And this paper discussed how
we secure our infrastructure.
And also, explains
our holistic approach
to the entire information
processing lifecycle.
And in this talk
here, I will closely
follow the material
in that paper.
And if you have not
done so already,
I hope that you go look up
that paper after the session
and read it.
Because there's a
lot more information
contained in there than I
can present here in an hour.
The security of
our infrastructure
is designed into all
layers of the platform,
starting from the physical
security of our data centers,
the security of our
purpose-built hardware,
the security of
the software stack,
ranging all the way to
the technical constraints
and processes that
form the basis
of our operational security.
To make it easier for you to
read the paper later and relate
it to this talk, let
me explain our layers
in slightly more detail.
As many of you may be used
to the layers of a more
traditional stack, I will
now explain why and how
our layers map onto it.
Google's security approach
stems from our focus
to deliver global
services at scale.
We do, however, understand
that many of our customers
and businesses may be
at different points
in their journey to deploying
all of their services
as internet services.
And as a result, some of you may
have a different stack mapping.
For example, we do
not treat the network
as our primary perimeter.
It's not our security barrier.
And that may be true
for companies in a more
traditional perimeter model.
At the first layer, the
hardware infrastructure for us
includes all the
underlying pieces
that go into securely
booting the hardware.
The service deployment
layer results from the fact
that Google's whole
infrastructure
is based on the notion
of separate services
that need to interact
with each other.
Our need to securely conduct
service deployment results
in strict requirements for
low-level machine end service
identities.
This means that our services run
on top of a curated operating
system, and that all
inter-process communication
is mutually authenticated.
At the data storage level,
we have multiple layers
of storage and file
system abstractions
above the physical
layer that are widely
distributed for availability
and reliability.
Security properties
include encryption at rest
as well as automated
deletion of data.
As Google primarily
delivers internet services,
securing internet communication
results in requirements
that span across the
network application
and deployment layers of
the traditional stack.
It also leads to an integrated
design across these layers,
such as deploying central
enforcement points that
provide services, such
as TLS termination
or protection against
denial of service attacks.
Similarly, securing
user identities
also drives requirements
and integrated design
across the application,
deployment, and usage layers.
Lastly, operational security
requires special capabilities
not only from the
application layer,
but also from the operations and
usage layers, such as providing
context-rich telemetry.
However, we also understand
that we can never rest
and that we need to review
our approach to security
constantly.
And for that reason,
we believe it
is important to be able to
think and act like an adversary.
For example, we conduct our own
internal [INAUDIBLE] exercises.
And we also have a
strong track record
in finding critical
vulnerabilities
in widely-deployed software.
And we use this understanding
to build principal defenses.
So in summary, to gain the
full measure of defense
in depth within Google, we
have design capabilities that
by necessity span and integrate
across multiple layers
of a more traditional stack.
The result for us is that we
protect both Google and Google
Cloud customers through this
defense in depth approach.
The homogeneity of
our infrastructure
and our integrated and
comprehensive stance
on security reduces
complexity and allows
us to deliver security
by default and at scale.
Through the remainder
of this talk,
I will provide more details
on Google's unique approach
to security and cover
which security features are
available to US
customers by default.
Those that are available to
you as distinct products.
And also, what is available
via partner solutions.
Don't be overwhelmed by this.
Don't try to read it.
I'll go through some
of these details
in the remainder of the talk.
So if we were to
map all the security
capabilities and the
features of Google's platform
against a traditional stack,
this is how it would look like.
You can see the
security capabilities
at each layer that combine into
our overall security stance.
As I mentioned
before, GCP is built
on top of Google's secure
infrastructure foundation,
which underlies all Google
Cloud offerings as well
as our consumer products,
such as Gmail or Photos.
The security of the core
infrastructure foundation
is something that Google
secures and manages by default.
Based on our own experience,
building our own internal cloud
platform, we continue to
externalize the existing
security capabilities
of our internal platform
so that you can secure your
own workloads with proven
technologies.
While I will not go
into any details,
when you look at the
stack later, please
pay attention to the key in
the upper right-hand corner.
It highlights the security the
platform provides by default,
the security that you
get via Google products,
as well as the security
solutions offered by partners.
And also note as
we go forward, we
are highlighting whether the
capabilities in each slide
is available to you by default
on our platform or as a product
that you can
configure and leverage
by the color box in the upper
right-hand corner of the slide.
So let's talk about hardware.
Due to Google scale,
we have the luxury
of designing and building
our own data centers.
These data centers
incorporate multiple layers
of physical security
and access to them
is limited to a very small
fraction of Google employees.
Again, we practice
defense in depth
by employing multiple physical
security layers to protect
our data center floors.
These technologies
include things
such as biometric
identification,
metal detectors, cameras, video
analytics, vehicle barriers.
And last but not least,
laser-based intrusion detection
systems.
That's right, laser-based.
Building our own
hardware allows us
to create infrastructure
that precisely
meets our requirements,
including what we
need for delivering security.
Both our server boards as
well as our network equipment
are custom designed by Google.
We carefully vet
component vendors
and work closely with
them to audit and validate
the security properties
provided by each component.
Besides security, this is also
a benefit to our performance.
So let me give you
an example there.
In our latest generation
Jupyter network,
we have increased the capacity
of a single data center network
more than 100 times.
Our Jupyter fabric
at the moment can
deliver more than 1 petabit
per second of total bisection
bandwidth.
To put this in other
words, the capacity
will be enough for
100,000 servers
to talk to each other with
10 gigabits second each.
Andromeda or the TPU
are other examples
where we have designed
custom solutions to achieve
much higher performance.
And now you may think,
well, this performance seems
impressive, but what does
it have to do with security?
And I will explain later
how this also allows
us to create better security.
For example, think
about what that
might do for our
ability to mitigate
denial of service attacks.
However, an example of
a purpose-built hardware
specifically for
security is Titan.
It's a custom ship that we
created for establishing
a hardware route of trust.
It's also a personal
accessory for Urs.
[LAUGHTER]
Titan is currently being
deployed on both servers
and peripherals.
And the ship allows
us to securely
identify and authenticate
legitimate Google devices
at the hardware level.
So in other words, with Titan
we have a strong, trusted route
for our boot process.
In general, our
server machines use
a variety of
different technologies
to make sure they are booting
the correct software stack.
In all of this, we use
cryptographic signatures
over low-level components,
like the BIOS, the bootloader,
the kernel, and the base
operating system image.
These signatures can be
validated during each boot
or update.
And all of these
components in this process
are Google-controlled,
built, and hardened.
For each new
generation of hardware,
we strive to continuously
improve security.
For example, depending on
the generation of the server
design, we root the
trust of the boot chain
in either a lockable firmware
chip, a microcontroller running
Google-written security
code, or as I just mentioned,
the Titan security chip.
Due to our trusted
boot process, we
can provision unique
identities to each server
in the data center that can be
tied back to the hardware root
as well as the software with
which the machine was booted.
The machine identity
is then used
to authenticate API calls to
and from low-level management
services on the machine.
And let me illustrate
that point for you.
Let's assume we suspected that
a machine was compromised.
After reboot, the machine
comes back with an identity
only if all components
of the boot process
could be validated.
As a result, the
successful reboot
indicates the machine is clean.
Furthermore, we have
offered automated systems
to ensure a service
run up-to-date versions
of their software stacks,
including security patches.
To detect and diagnose
hardware and software problems.
And to remove machines
from service, if necessary.
Here's another important point.
Within Google,
everything is a service.
We have fundamentally
designed our platform
to be a multi-tenant system.
That is, we do not assume
any trust between services.
So let me explain how this
works and how we secure
these services as a result.
We focus on four
key areas here--
service identity and isolation,
interservice access management,
encryption of interservice
communication.
And last but not least, access
management of end user data.
So let's talk about service
identity and isolation first.
As I mentioned before, all
inter-process communication
is mutually authenticated
and authorized.
It is important that we
provide strong access control
at an abstraction
level and granularity
that administrators and services
can naturally understand.
For that purpose, we apply
cryptographic authentication
and authorization at
the application layer.
Because we can
enforce authorization
at the application
layer, we do not
rely on internal
network segmentation
or filewalling as our
main security mechanisms.
I mean, however, to be clear,
we do use ingress and egress
filtering at various
points in our network
to prevent IP spoofing as an
additional security layer.
This approach also
helps us maximize
both our network's performance
as well as availability.
Each service that runs
on this infrastructure
is provided its own
cryptographic credentials
that they can use to
prove their identity when
making or receiving RPCs.
This allows clients to
ensure that they are talking
to the intended
server, and allow
servers to limit access
to methods and data
only to specific clients.
We also have a variety of
isolation and sandboxing
techniques for protecting
services from each other
when they run on
the same machine.
There is, obviously, regular
Linux process separation,
but we also have language- and
kernel-based sandboxes as well
as hardware virtualization.
And the approach that
we undertake here
is that we use more isolation
layers for riskier workloads.
For example, when running
user-supplied code on products
like Google App Engine
or Google Compute Engine.
As an additional
security boundary,
we enable very sensitive
services, such as the cluster
orchestration service and
some key management services,
to run exclusively on
dedicated machines.
So let's go to the next one,
interservice access management.
Access management features
provided by the infrastructure
allow a service owner
to precisely specify
who can communicate with it.
For example, a service.
Let's say a Bigtable
storage server,
may want to offer
some APIs solely
to a specific
whitelist of services.
The storage server
can then be configured
with a whitelist of the allowed
service account identities.
And this access restriction
is then automatically enforced
by the infrastructure.
Google engineers
accessing services
are also issued
individual identities.
So services can also be
configured specifically
to allow or deny their access.
All of these types of
identities-- machines, service,
and employee--
live in a global namespace
that is maintained
by our infrastructure.
This is separate from
end user identities.
I'll talk about them later.
This infrastructure also
provides a rich identity
management workflow that
includes approval chains,
logging, and notification.
For example, an identity can be
assigned to an access control
group via a system that
allows for two-party control.
And by two-party control, I mean
that one engineer can propose
a change to the group,
but another engineer,
the admin of the group,
needs to approve that change.
Our system allows secure access
management processes that scale
to the thousands of services
running on the infrastructure.
On top of this automatic
API-level access control
mechanism, the
infrastructure also
allows services to
implement their own custom
fine-grained access control by
giving the ability to a service
to check its central
ACL and group database.
So now, let's talk
about the encryption
of interservice communication.
Beyond authentication
and authorization,
the infrastructure also
provides cryptographic privacy
and integrity for RPC
data on the network.
To extend these benefits to
other protocols, such as HTTP,
we encapsulate them inside our
infrastructure RPC mechanism.
This gives application
layer isolation
and removes any dependency on
the security of the network
path.
As a result, encrypted
interservice communication
can remain secure even
if the network is tapped.
And if you think back to
2013, the Snowden revelations
described the threat
of tapping in detail.
To protect against such
sophisticated adversaries
trying to tap our private
interdata center links,
the infrastructure automatically
encrypts all infrastructure RPC
traffic that goes over the wide
area network between our data
centers without requiring
any explicit configuration
from the service.
Last but not least, let's
talk about access management
of end user data.
A typical Google service
is written to do something
for an end user.
For example, an
end user may want
to store their email on Gmail.
And to provide a
complete service,
the Gmail service may
call an API provided
by the contact service.
For example, to access an
end user's address book.
Just a minute ago, I was talking
about how the contact service
can be configured such
that RPC requests are only
allowed from the Gmail service.
Plus, perhaps some
other services
the contact servers
may want to allow.
While this sounds like a
good place to begin with,
this may still result in a
very broad set of permissions.
For example, this may
grant the Gmail service
the ability to request
the Contacts of any user
at any time.
However, as the Gmail
service makes an RPC request
to the contact service on
behalf of a particular end user,
we can do better.
Our infrastructure
provides the Gmail service
the capability of presenting
an end user permission
ticket as part of the RPC.
This ticket serves as proof
that the Gmail service
is acting on behalf of
a particular end user.
And this allows
the contact service
to require such a
ticket on each RPC,
and then return data
only for the end
user named in this ticket.
We have integrated
this capability
into our central user
identity service.
The central user
identity service
requires a user credential, such
as a cookie or an OAuth token,
and returns a short-lift
end user permission
ticket that can then be used
for subsequent RPCs related
to the user's request.
In our example,
the Gmail service
would request the end
user permission ticket
and would pass it down
to the contact service.
For any cascading call, the
end user permission ticket
can be handed down by
the calling service
to the callee as
part of the RPC call.
So let's go to the next
level of the stack.
And let's talk about
how data is stored.
By default, all data is
encrypted in one or more ways
with no extra effort
from the user.
The way that this works is by
providing storage services,
such as Bigtable, that abstract
away the physical storage.
Our storage services
then integrate
with a central key
management service
and can be configured
to use keys
from the central
KMS to encrypt data
before it's written to
the physical storage.
And I just told you about these
end user permission tickets.
The central KMS also
integrates with them,
so that keys can be tied
to particular end users.
The benefit from performing
encryption at the application
layer is that it also allows us
to isolate the infrastructure
from threats at lower levels,
such as malicious disk
firmware.
As you may recall, this is not
a theoretical threat either.
Nonetheless, we also enable
hardware encryption support,
both on our hard
drives and SSDs.
And we also track each
drive very carefully
through its complete life cycle.
And if a de-commissioned drive
cannot be securely erased via
a multi-step process, the
drive is physically destroyed
on premise, for example,
just by shredding it.
While the previous slide talked
about how we enable encryption
by default, we do provide other
options for our cloud customers
based on their trust
level and business needs.
For customers that need to
operate with minimal trust--
this is the very right-hand
side of the slide--
we support Customer-Supplied
Encryption Keys, CSEKs,
which enable them to maintain
their own separate root
of trust and push
keys at time of use
to Google Cloud via an API.
Those keys are
then stored in RAM
only during the time required to
perform the specific operation.
However, with CSEK the
burden and responsibility
of protecting and not losing
the keys falls with a customer.
Google has no way to recover the
customer's data if the keys are
inadvertently deleted or lost.
This is very easy to get wrong.
So any customer who wants
this minimal level of trust
and wants to use CSEK needs
to be exceedingly careful.
And must also invest in their
own key distribution system
to push keys to Google to
match the rate at which they
are being used in
their applications.
Operationally, the
customer-supplied key
is pushed to Google Cloud,
a [INAUDIBLE] is added.
And instead of the
Google-maintained key,
encryption key, the
customer-supplied key,
including [INAUDIBLE],
is used as the resulting
key, encryption key,
for the customer's data.
Another option-- and now
I'm talking about the middle
of the slide--
is our cloud key
management service
that we announced in the
keynotes this morning.
Cloud KMS enables
customers to leverage
our globally scalable
key management
system while maintaining
control of key operations,
including full audit
logging of their keys.
This solution alleviates
the need for the customer
to create their own
key distribution
system while still
enabling them to control
the visibility of their keys.
With Cloud KMS, keys created
and maintained in Cloud KMS
are used as the
key encryption keys
in place of Google's
default key encryption keys.
As you can see, we have several
different options for you
to choose from based on
your own levels of trust
and what is required
by your business.
In addition to providing
you with different choices
for encryption to
protect your data,
we have also created
a service that
allows you to classify
sensitive data automatically.
In February last year, we
announced the data loss
protection features in Gmail.
This year, we have expanded the
application of this technology
to Drive and have also
published this as an API
for you to integrate
with yourself.
And as you may have
seen earlier today,
there are many different ways
to leverage the DLP APIs.
They can be integrated into
mobile or support applications
so that data can be
classified and reacted
to during time of use.
For example, you can
flag data containing PII,
such as government ID numbers.
Social security numbers would
be one example as well as
credit cards and many
other identifiers.
Beyond protecting data
through encryption,
awareness of the
data content enables
you to customize your
controls and take actions
based on the specific
sensitivity of the information.
All right.
While we just took
a slight detour
into ways in which you
can protect and analyze
your own data, let's get
back to the infrastructure
Google has built to enable
secure internet communication.
Our infrastructure lives
on a private IP address
space that is completely
isolated from the internet.
To bridge that gap, we have
created a single point of entry
that we call the
Google Front End, GFE.
The GFE is a globally
distributed system,
but it provides a
logical enforcement
point for all traffic from
the internet to Google.
In the context of a
multi-tenant infrastructure,
it's important to
remember that GFE is just
another service that runs on
top of our infrastructure.
Before any service
can make itself
available on the
internet, it first
needs to register
itself with the GFE.
And the GFE then ensures
that all TLS connections
are terminated using
correct certificates
and follow best practices,
such as supporting
perfect forward secrecy.
When the GFE
receives the request,
it forwards it to the
corresponding service
using the RPC security protocol
I just explained earlier.
From that perspective,
the GFE plays the role
of a smart reverse proxy.
In addition to providing public
IP domain hosting and TLS
termination, GFE also provides
protection against denial
of service attacks.
For Cloud customers, we
offer similar capabilities
via the Google
Cloud Load Balancer,
which provides global load
balancing with anycast
IP, cross-region load
balancing, as well
as automatic
multi-region failover.
It also provides
TLS termination.
So let's drill into
protection for denial
of service attacks some more.
And I'll explain to you
how this works for Google.
Our first tier of defense
is that at the scale
of our infrastructure, we can
simply absorb many DOS attacks.
Remember when I talked about the
custom-build high-performance
network equipment?
Here is where we also
realized the security
benefits of high performance.
However, we do have multi-tier,
multi-layer DOS protections
to further reduce the chance
that any DOS attack might
impact services
running behind the GFE.
And let me explain that to you
in a little bit more detail.
Let's start from the top.
When the backbone delivers
an external connection
to one of our data
centers, this connection
passes through several layers of
both hardware and software load
balancers.
These load balancers
report statistics
about the incoming traffic
to a central DOS service.
That was actually
the first thing
I worked on when I joined
Google 13 years ago.
When it detects a DOS attack,
it can configure load balancers
to drop or throttle traffic
associated with the attack.
At the next layer,
the GFE instances
also report information
about requests they receive
to this central DOS service.
And this includes further
application layer information
that is not available
to the load balancers.
And the central DOS
service then again
can configure these GFE
instances to drop or throttle
traffic.
Since the Google
Cloud load balancer
is built on top of the GFE, you
can benefit from DOS mitigation
by placing your own
services behind [INAUDIBLE].
However, for customers that
need more fine-grained control,
we also have a set of
trusted third-party partners
that provide DDoS mitigation,
appliances, and services.
After DOS protection,
the next layer of defense
comes from our central
identity service.
The central identity
service provides
a login page for
end users, asking
for a username and password.
It can also challenge a user
for additional information
based on various risk
factors, such as the history
of previous login session from
a particular device or login
location, for example.
As we all know, humans often
remain the weakest link
in the chain.
It is just too easy
for us to fall victim
to a phishing attack or
to inadvertently install
malware that compromises
the computer,
and then takes control over it.
And even today, it remains
true that for most companies,
that spear phishing continues
to be the way in which they
get compromised.
It's an incredibly
effective attack.
And since humans are
the weakest link,
let's just use an example here.
Let's assume the infrastructure
was perfectly secure.
Everything is patched.
There are no exploitable
vulnerabilities.
None of that security matters
if the adversary can just
come in through the front door.
And since spear phishing attacks
remain exceedingly successful,
once an admin credential
has been stolen,
the adversary can impersonate
the admin at any time
to make arbitrary changes.
So what do we do about this?
To make phishing
less effective, we
have pioneered the
U2F security key.
The security key is a
hardware second factor
that can be associated
with an account
so that login is only possible
when the second factor is
present.
It is now also possible
for a domain administrator
to mandate a security key
for accounts in her domain.
We call this feature
security key enforcement.
I also mentioned malware before.
A malware compromise can
also be quite problematic.
For example, assume the
laptop of an administrator
was compromised.
As a result, the malware can
effectively make any changes
at once to a cloud deployment.
In some sense, it's game over.
So what can we do about that?
The best practice
is really to choose
a client platform
that's inherently
designed for security.
If an administrator was
solely using a Chromebook
running Chrome OS,
the malware compromise
would be exceedingly
less likely,
as Chrome OS is designed for
security from the ground up
and does not allow the
installation of software.
My recommendation to everyone
is to institute a policy that
effectively states
admin access is only
allowed if the admin
comes from a Chromebook
with a security key.
So because I believe
in this so strongly,
let me reiterate that.
The best practice is to use a
Chromebook with a security key.
I suggest that you also turn
on security key enforcement.
Many of you may not know what
security key enforcement is.
That's probably because we
just announced it this morning.
With security key enforcement,
customer administrators
on Google Cloud can now specify
that their employees or users
must be strongly authenticated
with a security key.
This is a security practice that
we have mandated for employees
at Google for many, many years.
So now you might
say requiring this
for all employees
may not be practical.
However, with security
key enforcement,
it is also possible
to enforce least--
sorry.
With security key
enforcement, it's
possible to enforce
these restrictions
on your high-risk
groups, such as admins,
which may be a compromise
for some deployments.
As a side note, since this is
a domain administrator feature
in which account recovery--
account recovery when
a security key is lost
becomes much easier.
So up to now, we have
discussed security properties
of our infrastructure.
And in the following,
I'll shed some light
on our operational practices.
We make a large investment in
monitoring the client devices
that our employees use to
operate our infrastructure.
For example, we ensure
that the operating system
images for these client
devices are up to date
with security patches.
We also control the applications
that can be installed and have
systems for scanning content
for security problems
related to user-installed apps,
downloads, browser extensions,
as well as content
browsed from the web.
Being on the corporate LAN
is not our primary mechanism
for granting access.
We instead enforce
and manage access
at the application level.
This allows us to expose
internal applications
to specific users only when
they are strongly authenticated
and are coming from a
correctly managed device
from expected networks
and geographic locations.
We call this
approach "BeyondCorp"
and have talked about
it extensively before.
Again you may rightfully
ask, how does all of this
apply to you?
So let me try to explain.
The previously mentioned Cloud
KMS as well as the Google Front
End are examples of key
abstractions at the core
of Google's architecture.
We pursue the approach
that where possible,
we design our infrastructure
to be logically centralized
at manage.
This makes it easier
to globally reason
about the state of
the infrastructure.
One key benefit of having
a logically centralized
abstraction is that we can
then create virtual enforcement
points in the
infrastructure to enforce
policy and leverage
the underlying globally
distributed physical
infrastructure to implement
them.
This morning, you may have
heard our announcement
of the Identity
Aware Proxy, IAP.
IAP makes it easy for you to
put an application on the cloud
and configure a central
policy in IAP that
ensures that only the
right set of identities
get access to your applications.
In the context of logically
centralized infrastructure,
IAP becomes your central
enforcement point
that gives you the ability
to assert policy on access
to any of your applications.
It helps close the
problem of policy gaps
due to large
complex deployments.
And you remember
when I said that you
should have a policy that allows
admins only from a Chromebook?
I expect that we will give
that to you as a policy option
IAP in the future.
In summary, Google's
infrastructure
is designed to build,
deploy, and operate services
securely at infinite scale.
Our Google Cloud
offerings are built
on top of that very
same infrastructure.
The security of
the infrastructure
is designed in layers, starting
from the physical components
and data centers to
secure boot, secure
interservice communications,
secure data at rest,
protected access to
services from the internet,
as well as the
processes we deploy
for operational security.
Many of these
security capabilities
are available on Google
Cloud to you by default.
We also continue to further
externalize our proven security
capabilities and make them
available to US customers.
Today, we announced
five of these--
IAP, Cloud KMS, DLP,
security key enforcement,
and shared VPC.
And these join previous product
and open source security
innovations with
many more to come.
So please, stay tuned.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING] as